on l'appelle la malédiction des pharaons
une vengeance contre les aventuriers
osant profané les tombes au sacré des
pyramides 1699 un navire polonais
transportant deux momies est hanté par
des visions spectrale essuie de
violentes tempêtes 1803 quatre membres
d'une expédition entre dans la pyramide
de khéphren et n'en ressortent jamais
1922 le tombeau de toutankhamon est
ouvert et une série de morts atroces
s'abat sur l'équipe responsable de
l'excavation lors des 91 années qui
suivirent aucune autre tombe ne fut
profanée jusqu'à aujourd'hui un des
producteurs 4 avec nous sur le film
scott silver avait vu un reportage à la
télé sur une archéologue américaine qui
avait eu cette idée en voyant un autre
reportage a été justement sur comment la
nasa les satellites de la nasa
radiographier le sol de mars pour voir
s'ils avaient des structures qui
existent lcd mais pourquoi pas la même
chose sur terre pourquoi au lieu d'aller
gratter avec des brosses à dents dans le
désert est allé déterrer des trésors
pourquoi on ne tourne pas les satellites
pourquoi on ne fait pas une sorte de
radiographie comme ça du désert en
egypte pour voir s'il ya des structures
justement se vit dans les sables ils ont
fait ça ils ont découvert en effet une
ville et à partir de cette idée là est
né le concept de pyramides et si
justement un groupe d'archéologues avait
la même avait recours à la même
technique et découvrez une pyramide plus
grande que toutes celles qu'on connaît
ensevelie dans les sables égyptien et au
moment où ils vont pouvoir rentrer dans
cette pyramide le printemps arabe des
événements qui suivent le prat heures à
provoque une réaction des autorités
égyptiennes qui leur demande de quitter
le territoire et eu évidemment en 24
heures pour plier bagage mais ne vont
pas partir sans aller voir évidemment ce
cas l'intérêt de cette pyramide
le script qu'on a reçue était
entièrement écrit comme un fou tout âge
moi je dois avouer que c'est pas
forcément le genre mais genre de films
préférés c'est pas et surtout pour une
première réalisation il y avait quelque
chose d'un peu frustrante de garder un
seul point de vue et de rester dans un
dans un schéma très rigoureux très
structuré en plus de ça on avait
l'ambition de faire un un décor quand
même assez important est de voir des
créatures donc l'idée de faire le film
entièrement avec une caméra qui bouge
dans tous les sens pour essayer d'éviter
de montrer quoi que ce soit c'était
surtout parce que j'avais ce que j'avais
envie de faire ensuite
l'histoire parle de de reporter enfin de
deux journalistes et qui viennent avec
leur caméra a filmé cette cette pyramide
dont je trouvais intéressant de
commencer le film avec leurs points de
vue pour mieux rentrer rentrer plus vite
dans l'action avec eux et mais assez
rapidement
j'avais envie de justement de de
dépasser ce seul point de vue pour
pouvoir être comme on dire avec les
personnages entièrement et pas seulement
derrière une caméra il y a cette manière
de caméra portée un petit peu
documentaire je pense que c'est plus
cette proximité des personnages qui
parlent plus aux gens dans cette
génération va dire youtube
voilà où les gens effectivement son
passent leurs journées à regarder des
clips vidéo de leurs voisins ou que le
skateur où je sais pas qui a fait donc
du coup c'est un format liberté
narrative qui est beaucoup plus forte
aujourd'hui qu'elle l'était auparavant
mais c'est un style qui serrait qui
appartient à notre époque et je pense
que les jeunes générations ont quelque
part c'est quelque chose qui leur
parlent même si les règles du fonds de
footage leur apporte peut laisser enfin
c'est ce procédé je pense leur parle et
moi quand j'ai découvert ce ce script
c'est j'ai vraiment vu un film que
j'aurais adoré voir en salle
à 12-13 ans après c'est on va pas se
cacher c'est effectivement c'est aussi
un moyen quelque part de faire des
économies aussi à dans le budget de
tourner plus vite on a tourné le film en
moins de 29 jours donc il ya énormément
d'action il se passe énormément de
choses donc voila ce ce procédé là nous
permet quand même d'avoir une certaine
liberté et de ne pas s'encombrer on va
dire d'une grue d'un de travelling et 2
des mises en place qui prenait des
heures
voilà ça ça me permet son père ted avoir
cet esprit un peu commandos et de pris
sur le vif